the nikon revolution pro controller is
one of the high-end alternatives for the
ps4 it offers several enhancements and
customizable functions but it does have
a few drawbacks the revolution is one of
two pro-style controllers licensed by
Sony but it's only available in European
markets so you'll have trouble getting
your hands on it if you're in the US it
costs around 90 British pounds which
converts to about 115 US dollars the
other Sony licensed controllers the
Razer Rhys U which is only available
overseas as well if you want to know how
brazzers controller performs check out
our review after this video and
subscribe to our channel for more but
for now let me break down the nikon
revolution the body has a sleek matte
finish with a strong grip that isn't
sticky despite it looking a bit heftier
it's fairly light weighing about the
same as the DualShock 4 adjustable
weights are also packaged which slip
into either side of the handles if you
prefer something heavier one thing you
must know this controller is not
Wireless it only works through a USB
cable with a proprietary 5 pin end a
metal screw cap keeps the cables secure
the enlarged face buttons stand out
immediately and they feel similar to the
stock Xbox one controller buttons which
isn't a bad thing there sighs neither
helped nor hinder our gameplay
experience the analog sticks are light
to the touch and offer consistent fluid
movement it's a significant improvement
over the DualShock for helping precise
aiming and overall ease of use it's also
the only ps4 controller we tested that
takes on the stick placement of the Xbox
controllers the revolution features a
disc like eight way directional pad that
felt responsive it's the best of any ps4
controller the d-pad sees limited use in
most games but it works great for
fighting games though series players
would naturally still opt for a fight
stick while l1 and r1 have a light touch
in a satisfying tactile feel the l2 and
r2 triggers leave a lot to be desired
they feel stiff and squishy and require
more force than necessary to hold down
which is a detriment in racing games and
shooters the triggers are also shaped in
a strange way that forces you to hold
the controller in a position that feels
awkward you'll be in a dilemma
choosing what's comfortable to hold and
what's comfortable for using the
triggers there are two pedals on the
back and each paddle acts as two
separate buttons depending on the way
the pressed the our buttons labeled m3
and m4 are responsive and effortless to
pull even in the most frantic situations
but not to the point where they can be
mistakenly pressed down and they're
sensible placement makes for the most
natural feeling paddle type buttons to
use since they reside right where the
middle finger is on the handles however
the inner buttons m1 and m2 are
inconsistent and tough to use making
them more trouble than they're worth
still two extra buttons is better than
none make on also stands out with its
robust software for full controller
customization even allowing you to tweak
the littlest things like the right
sticks response curve however this
requires a PC there isn't a way to
program the extra buttons on the fly
either
but you can save for profiles to the
controller and swap between them at any
time
now that you're aware of every little
detail of the nikon revolution if I want
to know how all of its features come
together when actually playing games
the precise analog sticks really shine
in titanfall too making it easier to
land shots and keep track of moving
targets and the m3 and m4 buttons made
jumping and connecting wall runs more
fluid which is a significant advantage
however and the triggers were tiring to
use deeper into play sessions and their
shape didn't stop nagging many of the
same advantages translated to overwatch
as always bunny hopping and using
ultimate abilities were easy to pull off
and using m3 and m4 buttons but the
triggers were even more tiring to using
this time around especially with
characters that you semi-auto weapons
like Farah and junk rack spamming the
triggers can wear you out in a longer
session giving the trigger stiffness the
main appeal of using a premium
controller in single player games would
be to make life a little bit easier by
mapping the dodge action to m3 or m4 in
both blood-borne and horizon zero dawn
escaping enemies and avoiding damage
while moving the camera at all times
make gameplay more fluid the placement
of those buttons also made these actions
feel natural
there's a lot to like about the Nikon
revolution from its fluid analog sticks
to some smartly placed buttons but
overall it's held back by some curious
design decisions like the trigger feel
and the trigger shape it's ultimately
too hard to ignore we've reviewed a few
other ps4 controllers so do yourself a
favor and check out what we thought of
razors and scuff gaming controllers and
as always if you liked this video give
it a thumbs up and don't forget to
subscribe to GameSpot thanks for
watching